今日はよろしくお願いします
話します
あぁそっかーっ
あれからもう6年も立つなく
国も年取ったなと思いますね
だって6年前って言ったら
19歳ですよ大学2年生のフォローを今はちょっとなんとなく始めてからもう6年
マナーが勝ったなと思いますねー
今日で6年なんですか
6年もやってんだなぁ
いやありがとうございます本当にここまで続けると嬉しいと思う
ゆっ
そうですね雑感破綻寸前ですねー
いや何かそう
南港なぜの話せなく危機と思うけど楽走って言われるじゃん曲
いろんな人にユーチューバーって楽市店前と思われるんですけど
まあそうじき言いましょう楽です
山手までよく考えると額じゃねーのそれだけじゃなくて女が鬼没面的にはなく
[音楽]
気持ち的には楽ただそれも時給人の考え方なんですけど動画作ってるのが楽しいから
続けているものの
これは仕事だと思っちゃうとスーパーブラックなことやってるな
そこらへんのブラック企業より
働いちゃうんじゃないかなく
なんだかそこを遊び感覚でやって
きたからこそここまで来たのじゃないかななるほど気はしております
いやー
ありがとうございます
ヤバイっすよねコア
チャンネル消そうかななんでサッカーでて使っちゃいけないんですかで使った簡単なと
思いますけどね
考えたらそうなるんですけどやらない善よりやる偽善みたいなところとかね
多分ソフトきちゃったをいういやーでもなかったなぁ本当に
バックにですよと思います弱に
小学生1人仕上がりますよ amazon で
選手の部族で発見されたそうなんですけど会いに行きますか
amazon で先制
の部族かー
歩くないですねドローンで発見されたぞ
なんかペヤングとか食べさせてみたいです
いやーめっちゃ変わりましたよそう浸透すると思いますめかした比べたらっ
始めた時痛くてユーチューバーってことはなかったん
まずで買ったと思う
コンピュータじゃなかったぞ
大学生の思い出作りだターン
あすぽんするんですねっ
2を言った記憶がないんですよ
凄麺か緊張し過ぎでがいて隣の席見るとトリンドル玲奈さんが入って可愛くて驚きまし
た
藤田ニコルさんどうでした強欲な壺国旗顔人気ヤバくないすか最近何ですか
う水な最近でも結局
なんでここでバシッと答えられないかというとね中火協会が飽和してきてるんだよ
確かぬなぜ今から様々な話になりません
普通に無視ですよ
そうなんかねえ
ここ一年で new to bar という言葉があまりに一般的に浸透しすぎて
テレビと変わんない気がしたんですよまずねテレビの方が頼みておりておいてますけど
ちょっと前までは何だろうユーチューバーって
みたいなんだか興味本位で見に来た人が入ってちょっとこれだったんですけど
最近もうなんか youtube 一回みてみて
興味ない人も見ない者に詰まってると思ったんだ影響であれば見続けるからね以前の大
爆発的な何かないんですよ
youtube 死体があっていう感じでまぁ良くも悪くも一般的に浸透してきて
テレビも見ない人みたいじゃないですか
けど見る人は見るじゃないですか
youtube もそんな感じで見る人は見るみんな瞳ないっていうかみんなが
ユーチューバーっってどんなのかっていうのが分かり始めてきてきます
悪く言うと目新しさがないんですよすでにももうないですね
一般もう当たればになってきたグループだまた新しいことを始めちゃいましたね
そうなんですよねぇそうなんですよあ今後なに頑張っていきたいかと言われると
今畑す
スタート所がっかりということ
1条会員になりゲットしたら僕体育館作れますね迷わずどうしてもユーチューバーに
なりたいと思う緩い
やめた方がいいと思いますだってだってだってですよ
もしもこれ絶対ユーチューバーになるって馬鹿なことしまくって
全然ダメだったらその子と何者こんなんですよ
黒歴史動画魚ことです
理事長は大学
に在学中に始められたです遊佐最近はなんかどうしてもそういう楽してお金が稼げる
みたいなイメージがあって
高校
卒業したらも youtube の
そういうことじゃないですよねたぶんいや清水気に入っていつかなみすぎ本当に垢野郎
がずいぶんなく
種類だしますまぁちょっと厳しい行寄せてもらうといや学校はちゃんと生きよと思う
なぁ
同氏を楽そうに見えているせいなんですかねこれます
ねどこからその実践が来るのが俺知りたいですがだってめっちゃなってユーチューバー
として仕事にするときめっちゃ怖かったですよ
210万300万ぐらいの時にユーチューバーとして生きるか普通の仕事を選ぶかで
めっちゃ迷いました
200万いっても迷いましておく
本当にこれで食っていけるのか何かあったらどうしようみたいなそれが今やもうなんか
俺はユーチューバー作ってくんだみたいな
学校行かなやつらもう
実は教育学部にいたんでー
あそそう学校の先生御多分になってたと思うんですけどなんか学校の先生も違うなって
思ってるどこかで多分
付くの先生になっています
てこのおおーー
声不安だったんですよ
怖いじゃないですか
レッツゴー買ったんですけど
他の吸い方がいいじゃんって思いません
なんだと気
いいところですかっ
ただ
僕が言いたいのはちゃんと選択肢をつくっていたっていうが目立った時4層や教師か
ユーチューバーって着せ next とったんですけど
若い方 the ユーチューバー1本見たい人は多いかなぁ
なく選択肢のうちの一つにユーチューバーあるのはすっごいいいことだと思うん
new 2番のせいで他の職業の選択肢を消すのはマジでも得ない
茶の締めありましたね山ほどありすぎて
一寸木ってどうしようもないことが多かったですね
6年間やってきて
いいことばっかり言ってばねつらいことも多かったですけど
乗り越えて今があるのかなと
思っておりますじゃあ始めちゃおうお忙しいところ
ありがとうございますそしてもし願います
アジアし新たに頑張ってくださいねっ
入って行きでちょっとインタビュー9 ct を撮ったんですけどチャンネル初めて
機
たり6周年6年が経ちました
本当に何を一番言いたいかというとここまで支えてくれた皆様
動画を見てくださる皆様本当にみなさんのおかげで6年間
youtube やってこれたかなと思っております
何いきなり換気性もあるやつはチャンネル誕生日ということで去年も5周年で出したと
思うんですけどほんとビビったねここ最近もユーチューバーと
ことが当たり前になってきてなんかちょっと嬉しいような寂しいような複雑な
新疆であるんですけどまぁなんとか
今も日本一でやらせていただいておりますた爪社長です新しく始め視察を畑っていう
チャンネルも初めて
すごい楽しいです今はパキッというか新しいことって楽しいから始めさそうの畑はこう
なんかもういやげようっていきますが今めっちゃ強いんですけど
youtube が楽しいという気持ちは6年経っても何も変わっておりません
何だろうと下に
油種ことですねっ
6年だって普通にはもう6年経ったんだなって思いました
なんかここまでやってきたなと思いつつも俺これいつ
や面倒かなーとか思いなかなかの ci だった読めないですけどまぁ今後も自分
らしく畑も盛り上げながら
肇社長のメインチャンネルを盛り上げながらだけがんばっていければいいなと思って
おります
6年間本当にありが
ございますとこともよろしくお願いしますじゃあ
グラスアイ
me
あっ